hello everyone and welcome to the
knockout phase of Dylan Doris a b-rabbit
challenge it's 11 Ireland vs. Hikaru
Nakamura the first pair we're gonna
check up on and the reason there's
already this position on the board is
because it's from Game one and we're not
gonna be showing game one but I will
show you what happened in Game one and
then we're just gonna go to Game four
the reason is it's not just gonna be one
match so they're gonna play for rapid
games and then if it's a tie they're
gonna go to Armageddon but that's not
like game over they're gonna have a
second match and the third match and
only then do you advance into
semi-finals so it's weird but it's more
chess so I don't know if I will be able
to show all of the games so that's why
sometimes I will do stuff like this so
you guys get you know a better idea of
what's happening so this is a position
from game one xi is threatening to win
Nakamura's bishop here and if Nakamura
goes back with Bishop let's say d2 then
you just move the bishop somewhere like
say Bishop to g3 and now you can start
advancing your past pawn and the white
wins this game
so instead Nakamura said I'm just gonna
give up the bishop here and I will try
to survive this endgame King captures
and c5 and rook to d1 so it's a rook and
Bishop against the rope which is
generally it's a theoretical draw but in
practice in over the board play I I mean
also in online play of course when the
clock is ticking white and not white but
the decide with more material almost
always wins this so you have to really
know how to draw this and I don't think
you can even know like there are
techniques and everything but there are
some positions that are just super weird
that you need to know to draw and very
very rarely well someone wrong so
basically in short this is what happened
of course you need to try and box in the
black king we have rook to e3 Rock the
c1 check we have King to d5 and rook to
d1 check so of course 11 try to do at
not allow this he also there's the 50
move rule if you don't if you don't
manage do it you know in 50 moves it's a
draw so King back to c6 rook f3 check
and sorry King f5 we look after
check King to e4 and now rook the f4
checks okay little by little boxing the
king in King III look the age for now
cutting of the King from the from
reaching the upper upper part of the
board king of three and now King the c5
we have King III Nakamura trying to
survive Bishop to e5
we have ripped the d8 now not allowing
the White King to approach and the
Bishop to d6 now so the King can now
approach here okay eight and now comes a
king to d5 we looked a five with check
Bishop to c5 check also blocking check
king of three and now rook the c4
now the king is cut off inside of this
box here so rook to be five by Nakamura
and the King to a five now we worked the
b8 and now look the c2 trying to box the
King even even further rook to e8 with
check we have King to f5 now rook the c8
attacking the bishop and the rook rook
the c3 check King to e2 in the now of
course King to e3 working t4 just
closing in the King even further now the
king is in this little box rook to e8
with check King f4 and now rook to d8
and rook to h3 now we have rook to e8
and Bishop the d4 now so little by
little 11 making progress King to d2
ending out Bishop to e5 now the King can
king can go over there we have kinked
the c2 end King to e4 now rook the d8
not allowing the King to cross but look
the c3 with check we have King 2b to end
now rook the sorry rook to b3 going
forward I looked the B to check to force
the King even further back so rook the
c8 and now rook all the way to h3
now we have King to c2 and only now rook
the HD with check King b3 and now Rock
the beat you with check with King to a3
and now the King is boxed in in this in
this little box here the arrows are
giving me some some problems King with
rook to be seven and now rook to e8 so
pinning the bishop King to d5 now rook
the c8 and
we have bishop the c7 now the king can
finally approach the black King we have
looked the h8 and now at Bishop to d6
with check King a2 and now came the c4
we've looked to see it with check bishop
the c7 again blocking the rook rook the
f8 and now Bishop to e5 we have looked
back to see it with check King to d3 now
and look the c1 so still trying to
trying to hold on we have worked the b2
with check King to a-1 and now comes a
rook to f2 with a check I discovered to
check we have King Tubby one end and out
Bishop to d4 so now the King really
doesn't have all that many squares rook
to d1 with check King to c3 in the now
rook to e1 and here Nakamura
I didn't didn't play the absolute best
move here instead of rook to e1 you
should go rook the c1 check and then
after the King moves let's say to b3
then you go rook to c2 but who would who
would find such things for example rook
to see one check
you could go King to b3 and then work
the c2 it's very interesting of course
Siddhant the rook cannot be captured due
to stalemate but these are these are the
things you should know when when trying
to draw the game rook against rook and
Bishop so here a nakamura wind rook to
e1 and now 11 just went king to b3 and
now there is no more defense for
nakamura nakamura played King to see one
but now Bishop the c3 and it's now it's
now game over all of these squares are
covered and whatever you play it's game
over once you move the rook rook to g1
you're gonna go rook to a2 and whatever
you play it's a rook to a-1 checkmate
whether you go here here the the point
is the bishop covers these two squares
so it's gonna be checkmate so 11 wins
the game won and the game 2 and 3 were
drawn and now we go into Game four now
let me just switch the colors here there
we go
where Nakamura has the white pieces and
11 only needs the draw to win the match
so let's see what happened so ii 4 and
also it's really interesting but i don't
think i've ever heard of anyone studying
rook rook and Bishop against rook but it
might be it
might be interesting to know you know
because it can happen to you like I
think it's even more rare than because
in classical chest I've ended up with a
bishop and night against the king and I
was able to win that in classical but
I've never gotten this either with a
winning side or with a losing side but
okay and this is Game four and now
eleven only needs a lot to win the to
win the match so II four we have E 5 9 f
3 and Knight to f6 Levin goes for the
Petrov defense and now Knight captures
on e5 so grabbing that pawn with d6
Knight to f3 and now Knight captures on
e4 Knight to c3 and now Knight captures
so the names of each attack captures
captures which is great as White has
very rapid development with both the
bishops with the Queen you can castle
anywhere you want Bishop to e7 and
Bishop to e3 now we have castles and the
Queen to d2 and this is a very popular
line everyone is playing at Knight to d7
and now a queenside castle now we have
c6 are preparing the five also making
room for the Queen in some cases and now
there are there are of course lines
where white goes King be one Queen a5
let's say C four then we can have a nice
Queen trade here which we've already
seen quite a few times on the channel
but here we have h4 also not a new move
we've seen a few games and rook to e8
continuing development with Bishop to d3
and now again not going for this a5
Queen a5 King b1 and then trying to
trade Queen's idea but rather Knight to
f6 and here there is a one game in fact
it was played by nakamura he played it
against Kramnik in the time memorial
tournament in 2010 which ended in a draw
with rook DT 1 was played but here we
have h5 and it is as of move 12th that
we have a completely new game so let's
see how 11 deals with this he goes
Bishop to g4 nicely nicely played
pins denied and there is no H point to
harass your bishop so we have rook DT 1
not really worried about bishop or
Knight captures here since you don't
really want to open up this file for the
white rook we have Queen to d7 and now
we have h6
but not by black by y
so h6 and now g6 of course keeping the
age file closed and night to d4 now
preparing f3g for g5 and so on
so a 611 wants to start expanding on the
queenside end now we have f3 Bishop has
to go back we have Bishop to e6 and now
Knight captures you could capture with
the Queen put some pressure on the pawn
here but then white white can evoke in
b1 c4 but 11 decides to improve his
center so he captures with the F pawn
also now the Queen can help out with the
defense of the seventh rank King to b1 a
nice prophylactic move by nakamura and
now b5 starting to expand on the
queenside nakamura starts pushing on the
King side we have g4 and now II five so
we have c4 here you want to get rid of
your doubled pawns but also you want
your light square Bishop on this
diagonal here so Queen to east six are
adding another defender and now Queen to
e 2 now Quinta e6 is is a good square
for the Queen however you don't want
your queen and king on this light square
diagonal as long as Nakamura has the
light square Bishop could be could be
very unpleasant so Luke a B 811 is
preparing to capture here open up the B
file for his rook and now g5 pushing the
knight back Knight to d7 and now King to
a 1 when the B file opens up you don't
want your King on the B file so 11
traits here we have captures captures
and now of course d5 you don't want to
lose your Queen and Bishop to b3 and now
this Bishop is an incredibly strong
piece not only for attacking purposes
but also for defending but if if black
can get some some pawn moves in it could
get a very unpleasant for nakamora as
well who absolutely must win this game
to get back into the match and to force
Armageddon so here you could try
something like a5 let's say if you're
interested in saving this pawn but 11
says I'm not interested in the pond I
want if you capture opponent just gonna
have an open file for my rook so tonight
the c5 he would definitely enjoy
grabbing this light square bishop of
course Nakamura will not allow that
Bishop captures captures and now
Nakamura just grabbed the d a6 pawn he's
not not worried
about anything as the bishop does a very
nice job
so what black black could do is move the
bishop and maybe try pushing this pawn
but it's very hard with this Bishop
controlling this diagonal so black first
needs to really consolidate and the
pawns here do a really nice job
controlling the dark squares so here you
could go for something like rook to e8
you could go rook to f8 there are
several ideas you could try but xi
decided to go Bishop to f2 now it it
comes with a tempo it attacks the rook
and also makes room for you to start
pushing your pawns but he wants to bring
the bishop over to f4 to completely
block off the position keep keep the
pawn defended however it doesn't work
and a Nakamura has a way to take
advantage of this move
so feel free to pause the video what
would you play here would white while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting the idea as
it's not an easy one to find and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show now I'm just joking it's nothing
with this rook its rook to eat you so
just attack that bishop so it's now
white who plays with tempo and now the
bishop has to move so here you could
first try something like rook to e8
bring the other rook over to be it and
only then reacted a bishop move however
11 just played Bishop to g3 as it was
his original plan to just shifted the
bishop over to f4
but now c4 and this is the problem for
Levin now Bishop captures here is a huge
threat now because if you play something
weird let's say you play rook or or
something you continue with Bishop to f4
then just captures captures and you
trade Queens
Queen captures captures and Bishop
captures and d5 wins you win the rook
and the game well the exchange in the
game so what you could try is rugby to
d8 to add another defender here but it
doesn't work just rook d2 and it's still
the same idea
you're gonna capture here and it's just
not good for black so instead a lemon
decided to play actively he decided to
sacrifice the exchange with the d4
Nakamura said okay c5 I either win the
Queen or you give up the exchange so
rook capture
son b3 a characterís and queen capture
son b3 so okay now eleven opened up
nakamura skin a little bit but nakamura
not not worried Queen captures and c6
keeps an eye on the a8 square so yeah
and no Luke 2:8 is possible and now rook
to b8 it does put pressure to the pawn
here but with with his rook here on e2
which is pretty much the temple that
this Bishop forced you know from from
there everything just to go going you
know according to the plan so King Tubby
won and now comes Queen back to f7 at
bringing the Queen to help out with the
defense as you kind of have to worry
about some like this it puts pressure on
the rook also Queen to g7 will be an
idea of checkmate so Queen back to f7
and now comes Queen to f6 Nakamura now
says okay I'm up material let's trade
Queens here
which he does sorry about that
otherwise if you don't just you start
pushing the past pawn you bring the
other look into the game and it's a just
a very easy position to play for white
so Levin captured here we have captures
captures and King to f7 11 will not win
the f6 pawn but c6 now we have King
captures an f6 and c7 going after the
rook rook the c8 and now look the c1 so
the past point is protected and now it's
not easy for black if this pawn starts
marching forward it's game over
so King is 711 will try to win the c7
point we have looked the c4 before
pushing the pawn so if this comes you
can move the rook and then bring the
King in so kink the d7 and now rook eat
the c2 defending and now g5 we have B
for Nakamoto starts pushing the past
pawn and now you don't really have a lot
of options here 11 decides to give up
the Jeep on with g4 we have F captors
and g4 and now Bishop to e1 so what's
the idea here you want to play Bishop to
c3 to cut off the rugs defenses of the
c7 pawn but now rook the e2 goes after
the bishop and the e5 pawn this
the g3 defending and only now be 5 so
Nakamura gives up the c7 pawn but he
still has the be passed pawn so rook
captures we have characters with Czech
captures and now g5 we have d3 by 11 and
now rook to e4 and it was in this
position that 11 iranian resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here point is whatever you do let's say
we push the pawn king defense the d1 is
a light square nothing to be done here
King b6 yes you stop this pawn but now
just g6 wins on the spot as captures h7
there's no stopping the the promotion of
the H pawn sure as xi was able to force
a win in that game want to completely
grind it out but nakamura comes back in
the match winning the game 4 and now we
are going into Armageddon so we'll check
what happens there and you and you know
it doesn't matter who wins the
Armageddon you are not immediately out
because this is only the first match
we're gonna have two more matches
between the two of them so weird format
we haven't seen anything like it so far
but you know we'll see what happens so
yeah that's the game I do do hope you
enjoyed it
and the previous one is well I would
like to thank Stefan told each Lodovico
third CD Bergamo Thomas Jeremy are two
poco lineman and Sergio obvious trivita
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot I really appreciate it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the Lin Doris Abby rapid challenge
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chest world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your weekend